good morning everybody here a few  stories we think you'll be talking about  today crews are inspecting buildings in  Puerto Rico to make sure they are safe  after a magnitude 6.0 earthquake hit  near the island last night the quake was  felt across the u.s. territory waking  people as they slept video shows what  appears to be a water main break but  there are no immediate reports of  significant damage the US Geological  Survey says the quake struck about 49  miles off of Puerto Rico's northwest  coast the quake hit as tropical storm  Karen moves closer to the island with  heavy rains and strong winds I was  following our David Beck nose Instagram  and Twitter account he was live tweeting  as this earthquake was happening but  were tow Rico must now be feeling it  enough enough Jesus that's okay we got  our fair share yes indeed we'll be  watching what happens with Karen